The good place is one of the most
interesting shows on television.
Not only does it explore morality ethics
and what it takes to live a good life,
but it features one of the greatest
twists in all of television.
I can't believe you figured it out.
This is going to be a
massive spoiler by the way.
Eleanor shells trap wakes up in the
afterlife, which we soon find out.
Consists of a good place and a bad
place around the good. As Michael,
the architect of her paradise
will neighborhood soon
explains pretty much every
religion got the afterlife wrong.
The closest to being right apparently
was a guy named Doug force set who
described the afterlife with 95% accuracy
while he was high on acid. One time.
Life runs on a point system
in every single thing you do,
adds or subtracts from your overall score,
get enough points and you get to heaven.
Don't earn enough and it's time to prepare
for an eternity of butthole spiders
in the bad place.
Each neighborhood is perfectly designed
to fit its residents based on how they
lived on earth and each of them
is paired up with their soulmate,
but it doesn't take long for us to learn
that Eleanor has been sent to the good
place by mistake in her real life. She
was a nightmare of a person to be around.
Eleanor reveals this to
or fig soulmate cheaty,
which puts him in a very
awkward position on earth.
She was a professor of moral philosophy
and the last time he told a lie,
it tortured him for three years.
Now he is faced with an
impossible moral dilemma.
He can either lie to
everyone in the neighborhood,
possibly condemning himself
to hell in the process,
or he can turn Eleanor in dooming her to
an eternity of aforementioned butthole
spiders. Eleanor begs cheaty to
teacher how to be a better person,
swearing that she will earn
her spot in the good place.
This promise to be better is
immediately challenged who died,
who loved Aristotle,
incharge of ethics. Plato.
Eleanor hates being around people who
think they are better than her and in the
afterlife everyone seems
to be her moral superior,
her neighbors Tahani and her soulmate
Gian you, for instance, to honey,
raise billions of dollars for charity.
In her years of philanthropy,
and Jianyu was a Tibetan monk who spent
nearly his entire life in a vow of
silence,
except it turns out Jianyu like Eleanor
has been brought here by mistake.
His real name was Jason and he was a petty
criminal from Jacksonville and he's a
moron fearing he will break their cover.
Eleanor persuades shitty to
teach Jason ethics as well.
All these mistakes happen because it
is the first neighborhood Michael has
designed and the errors have
some massive side effects.
This presents an even stronger moral
dilemma for cheating and Eleanor,
who's deception is tearing
apart the neighborhood.
As this not have moral
uncertainty reaches its climax.
We finally get the big reveal that Michael
is actually an architect for the bad
place and the four of them have been
brought here to torture each other.
Looking back on it. There were plenty of
clues from the moment the show begins.
Everything is not quite right in paradise.
There are stores on every corner with
frozen yogurt instead of ice cream.
Pizza parlors that only
serve pizza with pineapple,
and if you want some refreshments,
residents can stop by the
fountain of Clam Chowder.
It is tough to say which version of
hell would be worse if we died and were
immediately brought to hell.
We would probably be resigned
to our feet pretty quickly,
but having paradise within our grasp
and never being able to reach it would
drive us insane. Actually, the butthole
spiders would probably be way worse,
but this idea of torturing ourselves
and each other calls to mind.
A great quote from John Milton's
epic paradise lost where he says,
the mind is its own place and in
itself can make a heaven of Hell,
a hell of heaven.
What is being suggested in this passage
is that heaven and hell both coexist in
the mind. He's putting the emphasis on
this life and how some people make their
surroundings seem heavenly despite the
sorrows and difficulties they face while
others bring hell with
them wherever they go.
The show itself is based on a play by
John Paul Sartre called no exit in which
three deceased characters are punished
by being locked into a room together for
eternity.
It is in starches play that we get
the famous line hell is other people.
A quote that he says is
constantly being misunderstood.
He is not saying that people
are inevitably cruel and evil.
He is saying that we cannot really know
ourselves without taking how we are
regarded by others into account.
Other people are so important
to us because we cannot
complete the puzzle of who
we are without them.
Much of the plot is focused on how
the characters torture each other,
but what they found in each other was
simply an amplification of those aspects
which they despised most in themselves.
They're torment came from the fact that
the afterlife was a continuation of the
same self destructive patterns, vetted,
kept each of the miserable on earth,
cocaine and escape train already.
If each character had remained trapped
within their own self sabotage,
then it is likely that the torture
would've lasted forever. But Michael,
his grand plan fails as it all rested
on his certainty that Eleanor would
selfishly do anything to
avoid being found out,
but she is able to break out of herself
centered ways and confesses to being
brought to the good place by mistake
throwing a wrench in the entire plan.
Michael is forced to repeatedly wipe
their memories to see if he can keep the
torture going longer.
But the same thing keeps happening.
Eleanor constantly figuring out their
situation can be interpreted as her
ability to consciously
recognize her own self sabotage.
And by doing this she is able to break
free of its hold on her for Eleanor.
Learning about ethics actually works
and it seems to be the catalyst for her
becoming a better person.
Was that her lessons on ethics that made
the difference or could it have been
the initial decision to truly
devote herself to living
a better life and reading
about moral philosophy was simply
her vehicle for pursuing that.
It is unclear whether reading about
ethics actually makes you a better person.
One of the running jokes on the show is
how much people hate moral philosophers.
Cheese spent his entire life devoted
to living a virtuous life and the end
result was that it made himself and
the people around him miserable and is
clearly a parody as most philosophy
students don't spend two hours deciding
which brand of muffin would
be the most ethical choice,
but there was a stage and
learning philosophy where
you need to immerse yourself
in every philosophical viewpoint,
and this can actually make you
more confused than you were before,
but people who stick with it will likely
find themselves accepting some views
and rejecting others.
Students and philosophy professors are
uncertain about all kinds of things,
but having some principles for making
decisions in hard situations can make you
more decisive.
The question of how to be good.
It's such an abstract idea and
because life is so complicated,
any rigid worldview is bound to fail.
Each character shows how devoting yourself
to one limited branch of philosophy
is doomed to failure.
Take utilitarianism which says that it
is only the consequences of your actions
and not your intentions that matter.
If this were the pinnacle of virtue,
then Tahani would have been sent
to heaven and not to hell. Instead,
she ends up in the bad place because
all the good she did was for selfish
reasons.
We've already discussed how civies strict
obedience to the principles of content
has made a miserable cons.
Unconditional honesty would
seem ridiculous to most of us.
We would probably feel okay morally if we
lied to the Gestapo to hide our family,
or if we lied to a bunch of demons to
save our friends from an eternity of
torment,
but she still feels like this is wrong.
Jason shows us that ignorance of moral
values is not an excuse to be bad.
In the end,
it is Eleanor who rejects moral absolutes.
To live is to be confronted with problems,
each of them infinitely
and uniquely complex and we
almost never have the luxury
to sit down and map out every
possible consequence of our actions.
Take cheaty for example,
he is probably not the only student of
philosophy to spend hours dissecting the
famous trolley problem in a hilarious
scene where he was forced to enact this
problem in real life.
He realizes how useless all this
contemplation really was. Side Note,
I wonder how Michael an immortal demon
would answer the trolley problem.
So I would dangle a sharp blade out the
window to slice the neck of a guy on the
other track. As we smaller,
Sharp, our main guard,
oh,
Eleanor's case is particularly interesting
because her initial motivations to
save herself from eternal
damnation are not ideal.
But even though she takes up the task
of living a better life for selfish
reasons,
going through the motions
and internalizing what it
means to be good seems to
make her good.
It is Eleanor who takes these principles
and makes them the way she lives her
life.
She is the one who knows when to throw
out what it says in the book and follow
her intuition.
In the end,
it is Eleanor who proves she has broken
out of her self destructive patterns
when she is the only one of the four
to pass her test to get into heaven.
She truly shows how far her transformation
has come when she lies to the others
and says she failed the test.
She does this because they had made a
pact that either all of them or none of
them would get into the good place
knowing they would force her to go if they
knew the truth. Eleanor hides this in
order to keep her promise to her friends.
Eleanor was able to rise above herself
destructive behavior and because of this,
the people around her ceased to be hell
and instead became her greatest source
of inspiration.
If this video inspired you guys to pick
up one of those dusty old philosophy
books, but you're not sure where
to start, try Plato's republic.
Plato was so influential that Alfred
North Whitehead said that all of western
philosophy was simply footnotes to Plato.
You can get the audio book for
free when you sign up for a free
trial@audiblebygoingthroughthelinkinthedescriptionorbygoingtoaudible.com
slash
think big animation.